finding love isn't exactly at the top of
Christie Brinkley's list our favorite
uptown girl her 65 on Saturday and as
our special correspondent Kristine
Johnson found out dating isn't a major
priority for Christine dating at the age
of 65 versus like let's say 25 you know
are there are there things now that you
do differently
you just don't date that much for the
record guys this is 65 white bikini
channeling Meghan Markel and that
stunning red coat all smiles with her
look-alike daughter Saylor and at last
night's pre birthday bash being
serenaded by her other daughter Alexa
ray Joel yep Kristi's been goals since
we first met her on a photo shoot back
in 1983 I always think of myself as
chubby and when I'm doing the picture I
managed to pretend you know it's like
okay I said I remember posing for that
picture thinking what am I gonna do with
my hips where do I put them so I don't
look so large
are you that critical of yourself now
though well what's the first thing that
I said my camera you just suck in my
stomach for no eg has been with Kristy
throughout her career and can you
believe she is now worth an estimated
250 million dollars her latest business
venture is her sparkling wine label
bellisima Prosecco quick speed round
first job before you were famous I was a
scooper at 31 flavors ice cream do you
have a rear regret I didn't do Saturday
Night Live when they asked me what was I
thinking well here is to Christie
Brinkley and
anymore I mean she's not 65 no I think
she's just saying that doesn't make us
feel like she's not 65 years is not
[Music]